casimir est une seconde - qu'est-ce que
ça dit est ce que tu pourrais pour un
service je suis débordée j'ai trop de
clients
tu vois je vois que les bonbons à ta
place non merci
mais est ce que tu pourrais le faire
quelques courses des cours oui c'est
très facile j'en ai justement assez de
jouer à la marelle un bon très bien et
ben écoute voilà le panier la liste si
tu as des explications à me demander à
tous les manques d'accord toi tu savais
courcy a rien de plus facile vraiment
alors il te faut du pain de la tarte aux
pommes des carottes du pâté de campagne
de la crème fraîche des biftecks du
poivre des éclairs au chocolat et berry
y est c'est ça oui c'est ça alors il
faut que j'aille deux mois je suis chez
le pâtissier chez le charcutier chez le
boulanger chez le premier chez le
boucher chez l'épicier bon c'est très
facile
j'y vais bonjour je les salue françois
je suis épuisé que s'est il passé
trop travail je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui mais tous les enfants
voulaient des bonbons en même temps je
finis à l'instant c'est ce qu'on appelle
le coup de feu c'est ça s'apprend markit
on passe la main quand les affaires
marchent bien tout à fait résolus cela
dit j'ai plus un seul caramel il faut
que j'aille à la réserve où chercher
c'est pas grave je les je garderai
tonkin sport dont l'absence à propos les
courses que tu voulais faire aujourd'hui
donc je n'ai pas eu le temps
mais heureusement casimir n'avait rien à
faire et il a bien voulu aller à ma
place oui casimir et j'espère que tu
n'auras pas de mauvaises surprises on
verra bien si c'est tromper dans
certaines choses sont gentils avec les
enfants de nuit a qu'une des insurgés à
total et enfin pas tout à l'heure
bon alors qu'est ce que je vais faire
dans le cast de jute kelly l'année alors
qu'elle il
je parierais que casimir a eu des ennuis
en faisant ses courses
heureusement les tableaux noirs que
j'avais préparé portée incroyable je
n'ai jamais vu ça quelle ville casimir
que tu est il arrivé au coeur à françois
écoutez il faut faire quelque chose dont
on ne trouve plus rien chez les
commerçants de l'île
pourtant casimir hier j'étais fémur
course et il m'a semblé qu'ils avaient
tout ce qu'on peut souhaiter par écouter
hier peut-être mais pas aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas trouvé une seule des choses
que julie m'a demandé de lui acheter
où es tu allais je suis d'abord allé
chez le boucher pour aller acheter une
tarte aux pommes
il n'en avait pas ensuite c'est le
boulanger pour acheter des rillettes
il n'en avait pas non plus chez le
pâtissier il n'y avait pas de bifteck
casimir quels sont les commerçants chez
qui tout allait bien je suis allé chez
le boulanger rien chez
l'épicier sheila et renier égarements et
ensuite chez le charcutier chez le
pâtissier est issu le boucher aussi chez
et voilà les enfants s'en venait et
venir on va faire un jeu venez vite les
enfants casimir avait des courses à
faire et ça n'a pas très bien marché
il a besoin de votre aide casino moi
même pas du tout moi j'ai pas besoin de
l'aide de personne et tu es sûr que des
mines casimir quelle était ta première
course je suis d'abord allé chez le
boucher pour acheter une tarte aux
pommes
il n'en avait pas vous seriez allé chez
le boucher pour acheter une tarte aux
pommes les enfants le casino une tarte
aux pommes se trouve chez le pâtissier
ou en bois etc ou de france franchement
qu'il vaut mieux se donnent toute la
liste des commissions
j'écouterai attentivement jus pour ne
râle je crois que c'est préférable
casimir et vous si chez vous vous avez
casimir
alors ensuite casimir a dû aller acheter
du pain
jekel commerçants s'est il rendu du pain
à 15me évidemment été acheter son pain
chez le boulanger ensuite casimir avait
des 40 à acheter alors chez qui les
carottes c'est l'épicier s'inquiètent
les carottes chez l'épicier d'habitude
plus d'allemands ensuite casimir voulait
acheter at être en pagne le délicieux
pâté de campagne chez le charcutier
ensuite casimir devait acheter de la
crème fraîche
j'ai pu très bien c'était chez le
craignais la crème fraîche
ensuite un bon bifteck
le bifteck chez le boucher ensuite il
devait acheter du poivre très bien ri
steed chez l'épicier le poids ensuite un
éclair au chocolat ou café kazim et que
c'était les deux heures dont deux
éclairs pâtissier c'est un pâtissier les
éclairs chez le pâtissier et enfin les
rillettes les rillettes charcutier et
bien voilà casimir nous avons fait la
liste complète de des courses et
maintenant tu n'as plus qu'à partir
annonce françois ce n'est plus possible
comment casimir tu ne veux plus faire
les courses de julie à je voudrais bien
mais je ne peux plus mais pourquoi
casimir les enfants ont tous dit oui
mais qui vient de déchirer toute la
liste des courses en petits morceaux
[Musique]